in 2016 recreational marijuana became
legal in california creating a dynamic
new industry in the golden state but
since marijuana is not fully legal at
the federal level this has created a new
gray area when california cannabis
products are sold in states that don't
have full legalization elliot lewis the
ceo of catalyst cannabis company is
hoping to bring more awareness to this
problem through a recent lawsuit he
filed against the california department
of cannabis control the lawsuit alleges
people are gaming california's system
and diverting untold millions of pounds
of legally grown cannabis to the illicit
market across the u.s it claims
california's industry regulators are
fully aware of this but not doing
anything about it here's where the main
issue lies according to the lawsuit
phony straw man operations known as
burner distributors will purchase
cannabis from a legitimate grower
they'll pay state cultivation taxes but
not the required state excise taxes
burners will then sell the legal
cannabis on the illicit market either
within the state for prices that legal
dispensaries can't compete with or out
of state under legalization this should
not be happening since state regulators
should be using the track and trace
system designed to prevent this type of
problem but the lawsuit alleges
regulators are satisfied with collecting
cultivation taxes and simply don't
pursue action against burner
distributors instead the state only
investigates people who are reported by
others and have made the purposeful
decision to turn a blind eye to illegal
burner distros in order to keep that
excess cultivation tax money flowing and
the state does collect plenty in taxes
in 2020 more than 1.1 billion dollars
was brought in from the legal cannabis
industry and it's on track to exceed
1.27 billion dollars in 2021 however the
lawsuit does not seek monetary damages
instead it is seeking a court injunction
that would compel the state to shut down
the alleged illegal cannabis
distribution network while the
allegations are confined to california's
system and the requirement for
distribution permits the problem of
burner distributors has the potential to
gain national attention if more states
decide to fully legalize
you